hi hi hi I'm Justine I'm Desiree and we
are finalists in the Yahoo talent show
competition this weekend we'll be
travelling to New York to compete with
four other finalists who are also trying
to get their own show on Yahoo so we
need your support this right here
talent show yahoo.com we'd really really
appreciate your support voting starts on
December 12th and it goes through the
13th if you don't have a yahoo account
then you can sign up for one voting
closes on the 13th at midnight and on
the 14th the make somebody's calling you
oh you've done this so thank you to
everyone and if you can go check us out
and or just stars thank you so much
thank you by a missile talent show -
yeah - calm
[Music]